provide an accused of ignoring victims
and hero cops to heat Praise on
lawmakers pushing gun control Biden
welcoming the three Tennessee lawmakers
who face expulsion after a Rowdy protest
at their state's capital Biden using the
event to slam Republicans
what the Republican legislature did was
shocking it was undemocratic and it was
um
without any president if you stand up
for our kids you're standing up for
Community safer communities and
Democratic Values
the Biden median is not the only thing
getting attention on New York Times
columnist wants Americans to trade their
guns for bear spray arguing that it
would be more effective at stopping a
home Invader Charlie you are familiar
with bears is that going to work oh yeah
no that's not going to work and it is
kind of amazing in some cases you're
considered a bear yeah
um I don't know what that means
but uh no and and anyone who lives in
Bear Country can tell you that if you
have the option you're going to
definitely want uh the gun but also he
does this at a time when he's launching
his campaign and talking about Freedom
well there's no greater Freedom more
important freedom than the freedom to be
able to defend your family defend your
home uh using a gun and uh but I love
these guys that show up here
um you know it's all undemocratic
because they didn't get their way yes
it's not undemocratic because of you
know they stormed the building and they
it was an Insurrection is what it was
yeah but it's all undemocratic because
he didn't get his way yeah one of the
things Greg that they said earlier today
was that they get to the White House and
they are trying to explain that no they
actually did break the rules yeah they
did they did break the rules and then so
the Republicans in Tennessee said okay
here's we're going to do I'm not saying
it was the smartest tactic because in
the end here you go you have a photo op
that benefits both Biden and the
Tennessee three well they it's a it's an
important lesson in modern culture that
performance is more important than
people right who cares about the
families of the victims or the heroic
cops that stop uh more Carnage they
rewarded these hucksters for their
Stellar acting in a costume drama
because it was a costume drama and this
is the the modern kind of left-wing
party the hyper dramatic always wins and
substance doesn't matter and how fitting
is is it that that story uh the
spotlight is steered away from the cause
of the shooting it's not about the gun
it's about a disturbed person who is a
member of a protected class right whose
Manifesto is under lock and key if she
were wearing Maga hat this would be an
entirely different story
judge what do you think about the
the White House doing this on their on
their day where he announces his
re-election and you can see you can just
imagine that for the next 18 months
there's going to be a lot of box
checking that's going on yeah well this
is a number one box that he could have
changed when he had the house and uh and
the Senate and the oval but it's all
about guns and I have to tell you
um in one of the Articles the Democrats
are saying were caught in a spiral in
which perceptions of rising crime lead
more people to purchase firearms
perceptions of rising crime crime is
rising police are being defunded I mean
the truth is people are not being
arrested they're not being prosecuted
they're not being convicted and they're
not being locked up at all so they're
saying that you know we've got this
perception issue and crime really isn't
up and so if you think you need a gun
you're stupid so what I did was I
checked out this bear spray and the bear
spray only lost last seven to nine
seconds
no but the bear spray only lasts seven
to nine seconds so if you got a criminal
coming at you with a knife in your home
and it's it's like three in the morning
say hang on I gotta get my ears
I mean the whole thing is absurd the
other thing is this we shouldn't lose
sight of this these three said they they
went to the Capitol to protest about gun
violence and there had been a horrific
school shooting yep in Nashville at the
covenants Christian School and those six
people died and the president didn't
call them and they didn't get invited to
the White House and Harold what when
when you have a president of the United
States who now wants another four years
in the office
what kind of message does that send to
people who are victims of crime so I
differ a little bit in the way we're
talking about this I do agree with one
thing that these young these two young
men in this young young lady the law of
the lawmaker they broke the rules on the
floor didn't warrant expelling them uh
they were trying to force the
legislature to take up uh something on
guns and the the leaders there the
Republican leaders in the state house
didn't want to do it and they chose to
take a bullhorn down it was the wrong
thing to do but you don't expel someone
when I was in Congress a lot of guys and
women would have been expelled for some
of the Antics maybe myself for some of
the Antics that were perpetrated on the
floor now what did you do I would love
to know yeah but we yelled at people we
yelled them down we tried to gave them
down but I mean that that's just but
it's just the passion's got going but
here's where I agree with you and Dana I
I'm a second amendment guy I think guns
should be people should be able to own
guns protect themselves it's a
constitutional right but where I differ
a bit is when we look at a different
category of things we talk about on this
show we did yesterday black on black
crime which talked about how crimes are
generally perpetrated if you whatever
race you are generally someone of your
own race that perpetrates that crime but
there's no doubt there's a lot of
violence in terms of black on black
crime now
ghost guns are an issue we we can we can
say that some of the things that people
are talking about doing taking guns or
new gun restrictions are the wrong way
but we are kidding ourselves if we
believe that it's okay in some
neighborhoods in some communities for it
to be easier to get a gun than a new
book that it's easy to get a new gun
than an education you talked aptly and
rightly so you and Greg yesterday judge
and you have for a while about the need
for more quality education products and
opportunities I was at a great dinner
here in New York last night at the
Success Academy something that some of
my Democratic friends don't support we
have to be willing to do all of these
things but if we can only side with the
things that we like or check the boxes
that we like then we're not going to
deal with all of this ghost guns are a
problem that doesn't mean that legal
that that we should not allow every
people who obey the law who don't beat
their wives who don't have a criminal
record that they should be able to have
guns but I'm a firm believer that
children in neighborhoods in Chicago and
Baltimore my hometown in Memphis in New
York we have to deal with this issue
honestly and seriously can I ask at the
table anybody who wants to answer why do
you think we don't have the manifesto
yet from the Nashville shooter
they said it was too dangerous yeah
which means it who's it dangerous to
right that's that's the question and it
and and I think they would argue it's
dangerous to the uh the protected the
protected class and the agenda do you
think it could be that the manifesto
might encourage or incite someone else
to do something around the country who
might feel the same other manifestos
that is the point why is this being I'm
not protecting that I don't know okay
okay so given that why is this Manifesto
being treated differently is it because
of the person who wrote it that is the
question and why is it called a
Manifesto I mean honestly we've got to
change that language that's a good catch
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else